il est ce que ce genre de rôle vous
donne pleinement satisfaction
c'était assez facile à faire bon au
caractère c'est si forte j'aimais bien
le personnage s'était satisfait a fait
un travail très très fort on dit aussi
que depuis que vous avez joué dans
emmanuelle et dans les différents
numéros des mêmes les manuels à
emmanuelle b 23 vous essayez de sortir
de ce genre de rôles que vous ne vouliez
pas jouer toute votre vie je pense pas
qu'on puisse parler des genres emmanuel
on peut pas le comparer avec diageo
quand même et je trouve que
je ne sais pas j'étais très ému quand
j'ai lu 7 livres
et
je voudrais bien faire parce que je
pensais que c'était une femme s'est
libérée qui a fait et à la fin le choix
l'a choisi pour l'amour donc
s'il ya quelques scènes disons sensuelle
ça me dérangerait pas
non
mais maintenant que je pense que je
préfère faire une comédie
ce même juge a qu'un lorsqu'on réalise
ce genre de film d'après ce roman
comment fait-on pour ne pas tomber
du romantisme à l'érotisme au
pornographiques et lille sont les
limites à ne pas franchir
c'est toujours que la vie ferrante à
bord entre le mot érotisme et
pornographique la différence je crois
que quand un acteur peut s'abriter à une
psychologie quand un rôle est
parfaitement écrit je crois qu'on peut
demander beaucoup de choses à une
comédienne et un comédien
je crois que ce livre était tellement
écrit on aurait plus ou moins de
n'importe quoi si ce via c'était
tellement bien écrit ce livre blake
tellement à suivre c'était tellement
beau il ya une tête psychologie pour
l'aider il y avait aucune gratuité en
fait là qu'est ce que c'est pour le
graphiste voir une porte de personnes
qui font l'amour on pousse pour porter
un autre qui font l'amour et puis ça
pourrait on comprend dans sa voiture et
un corps de chien qui fait l'amour avec
un champ derrière c'est ça la différence
pour moi il ya un vrai scénario
peut-être moins chatterley mais alors
qu'elle est là qu elle est si vous
voulez d'après vous quelles sont les
différences essentielles entre ce film
dont on vient de parler cydia et estelle
est ce que vous avez tourné auparavant
emmanuel agetur enfin je crois qu'à part
il n'y a pas de différence essentielle
je crois que
la raison de mon succès je touche du
bois pour suis là c'est que j'ai
toujours essayé de suggérer les choses
et laisser au spectateur la peau cité de
projeter à travers les images on voit
pas grand chose ils ont toujours un
pouvoir des tas de choses on voit jamais
un sexe on va jamais le nommé de choses
difficiles d'accord oui mais cela dit
sylvia kristel avez vous l'impression
que le même nombre de spectateurs irait
voir vos films si on suggérait un peu
moins les scènes qu on le fait dans les
films que vous tournez si on vous voyait
moins nu est ce qu'on aurait autant vous
voir
soyons c'est
la preuve qu'elle a dans tous les films
que j'ai faits je me déshabille et pas
du tout marché voilà on va y arriver
ça va enfin je voudrais dire que je très
important pour sylvia je crois que le
succès des manuels en a fait une star
oui et que après après emmanuel 1 parce
que j'ai fait quelques liens avec l on a
profité d'une ou du monde du nom de
sylvia kristel on s'en est servi pour
faire des tas de films pour trouver de
l'argent pour les parce qu'il faut
beaucoup d'argent pour faire un film non
nagées m'a donné possibilité acide est
vraiment une comédienne je crois à
l'exception des cha cha vol oui
justement vous avez même vous avez même
je les lui dans un article de presse
nous a même dit un jour je cela m'ennuie
que le public me considère comme
simplement une actrice qui ce qui se
déshabille au cinéma oui oui c'est un
mineur mais je pense que en france j'ai
pas lu tellement ces problèmes ils sont
très sophistiqués dans sept pays c'est
en allemagne
7 pays difficiles en italie aussi un
petit peu
ça départ de pays à pays en amérique
j'ai fait des autres choses déjà je fais
chose pour la télévision avec tony
curtis et
donc concorde avec un avion et puis une
comédie alors là ils savent pas comment
ils se rappellent des manuels mais ça
c'est pour eux c'est un succès de il ya
sept ans il faut encore continuer à
vivre alors j'ai jacquin qui avait-il
dans emmanuelle on en vient on en a déjà
un petit peu parlé tout à l'heure qui
justifie le fait qu'il y ait un si grand
succès un succès qui dure toujours je
sais pas il ya eu 200 millions d'entre
eux quelque chose les visages se dire
que je suis toute à l'heure est
important c'est là qu'ont été les
premiers à bénéficier de cette ouverture
la censure donc on était le premier film
érotique
visible et comme le film était très pur
malgré tout c'est de l'eau de rose pour
certains quand vous voyez des films
pornographiques est mené c'est de l'eau
de rose je crois qu'on a été le premier
genre de film sensuel qui permettait aux
gens d'aller voir des films sans suez
sans sentir coupables de voir quelque
chose de dégoûtant ça c'était à peu près
si vous voulez on m'attaque et de 2,2 de
faire des images fils tic etc enfin je
crois que c'est la raison du succès
[Musique]